is the new villain ted movie truly
excellent or bogus
turns out just a little of both here are
the five best and five worst things in
bill and ted face the music
bill and ted face to music opens with a
wedding as bill and ted's ex-stepmom
missy is now marrying ted's little
brother
deacon after delivering a strange yet
heartfelt wedding speech
bill and ted honor the happy couple by
providing the music for their first
dance the world premiere of the first
three movements of that which binds us
through time
the chemical physical and biological
nature of love
an exploration of the meaning of meaning
part one one two three
four
what follows the bizarrely hilarious
mishmash of throat singing bagpipes
trumpet
and who knows what else as missy and
deacon try and vain to dance to the
strange noises but instead of producing
it's clear just how desperate bilinta
had become to try to compose the song
that rufus told them they were destined
to write between the song and their
speech
it's a perfect reintroduction to bill
and ted showing that they're still the
same lovable doofuses from the first two
movies while also acknowledging how the
intervening 25 years have weighed on
them
while we're glad that bill and ted's
wives princesses joanna and elizabeth
get a little more to do in face to music
than in the previous two films their
subplot winds up being one of the film's
weaker links
early on their much older selves arrive
on a time machine of their own to take
their younger counterparts to find a
reality where they're happy with bill
and ted
but ultimately the princesses realize
the happiest and the present with their
husbands
which begs the question of why the
elderly princesses felt the need to
intervene in their lives in the first
place
even if the future princesses actually
traveled back in time to save their
marriages
that doesn't make sense when we learn
the real reason why joanna and elizabeth
have requested marriage counselling
it's not as is first implied because
they are frustrated by their husband's
codependence
it's actually because they're worried
about their emotional well-being
after 25 years of trying to write a
world-saving song
and coming up empty so it seems like
their marriages weren't even in trouble
to begin with and the idea of leaving
their husbands only ever occurred to
them when their future selves showed up
what was the point of it all we may
never know
at the end of bill and ted's bogus
journey we were introduced to babies
little bill and little ted
in face to music we learned that those
babies are actually bill and ted's
daughters
theodora preston and billy s logan and
that they've grown up to be their
dad's biggest fans after seeing their
dad's disappearance of the future
billy and thea embark on an excellent
adventure of their own
trying to assemble the greatest band the
world has ever seen to help their dads
perform their song
i feel so bad for him they've been doing
this on their own for the longest time
yeah i wish there was some way we could
help him out you know yeah
but billy and thea's greatest
contribution to bill and ted face to
music are actresses bridget lundy payne
and samara weaving themselves who recall
the same exuberant energy that keanu
reeves and alex winter brought to the
original film
yet billion thea aren't carbon copies of
their dads either
as evidenced by their more thoughtful
approach to problem solving
and surprisingly advanced understanding
of temporal dynamics they're a
delightful addition to the world of bill
and ted and we wouldn't say no to seeing
billion thea's excellent adventure at
some point down the timeline
from excellent adventure to face to
music bill and said have always managed
to remain the same big-hearted
well-intentioned music-loving bozos that
we first met as teenagers
yet in bill and ted face to music when
bill and ted decide to head to the
future
to see if they can get their world
uniting song from their future selves
nearly every version of themselves that
they meet is a total jerk
they start out by traveling to 2022
where they meet themselves as bitter
washed up has been
who have been left by their wives and
are living in a van their next stop is
2025
where they find themselves squatting at
dave growl's mansion in an attempt to
pass one of the foo fighters front man
songs off as their own
the 2025 bill and said even wind up
attempting to kill their past selves
even though that would lead to their own
destruction then they head to 2030
but they're in prison and are determined
to swap places with their 2020
counterparts
not only does it not make sense that
none of these billowed tents would have
any memory of their universe aligning
concert in 2020
but their characterization is light
years from the previously consistent
twosome we've come to know and love
while most of the members of bill and
ted's band that perform at the end of
the film were carefully
curated by their daughters kid curry is
a gift from the universe itself
at the beginning of bill and ted face to
music we learn that the very fabric of
space and time is unraveling with people
disappearing from their own times
and getting transported into totally
different times and places that's how
kid cudi winds up
dropping onto bill and ted's cul-de-sac
in san dimas writer steer and billy have
returned home with their newly assembled
band but while kid cudi is a fun
addition to the band he brings a lot
more than his rapping and music
production skills to the table
it turns out that this version of kid
curry is obsessed with quantum physics
and as soon as billion thea explained to
him what's happening with the universe
he instantly grasps what's going on
for the rest of the film kid curry
serves as a group's resident time travel
experts whom they consult whenever they
have a particularly tricky quantum
conundrum it's fun to have a member of
the group who talks about time travel in
a more academic way
than we're used to from billing ted
films even if other characters rarely
understand him
the great leader has a very different
view of history than her late husband
rufus and rather than attempting to help
bill and ted
she constructs an assassin robot to kill
them given the name
dennis caleb mccoy the robot skips
around the timeline
determined to exterminate his targets
eventually he succeeds
killing himself in the process and winds
up sending all three of them to hell to
negotiate with death
from then on a dennis is just a strange
tagalong who acts more like a lost child
than a killer robot
overall his inclusion seems intended to
add laughs but instead it winds up
dragging the film down with dennis
failing to live up to the high energy
and zany comedy of the other characters
even his dancing at the end feels a
little dull and disconnected which is
unfortunate when everything else about
the final concert comes together so well
after spending most of the three movies
under the impression that the fate of
the world rests entirely on their
shoulders
bill and ted realizing their climax of
face to music that it's their daughters
not them who have the potential to save
the universe it still fits with what
rufus told them in the first movie when
he explained why he had to ensure bill
and ted weren't separated
you see eventually your music will help
put an end to war and poverty
it will align the planets and bring them
into universal harmony
it turns out that bill and ted needed to
stay together so that billy and thea
could grow up side by side
listening to music and hearing their
dad's stories of traveling through time
does it make complete sense with what
we've previously been told
well no but that's par for the course
for a bill and ted movie besides the
reason it works isn't because it's an
intricately conceived plot twist but
because it shows the growth of bill and
ted's characters they began the
franchise desiring greatness for
themselves
but they end it by showing that they're
willing to step away from the spotlight
without a second thought handing it over
to their kids for the greater good
when you think about it the great
leader's plan is a little ridiculous
she tells her daughter kelly that she
believes that the deaths of bill and ted
will usher in the events that lead to
their utopian future and repair the
universe
not their song performance but that
doesn't drive at all with what we were
told in the first film
or even with the world building of the
third film the great leader knows the
precise date and time of the concert
which will repair the universe
and lead to their society yet somehow
reasons are preventing the concert by
killing bill and ted is the better
option there's no evidence that seems to
support her belief
and by trying to prevent events that
already happened earlier in her own
timeline
she seems to be risking catastrophe
maybe if the future was a disaster it
would make sense that she would try to
prevent it but as it stands
it doesn't make sense that she'd try to
stop the events that create her own
utopia
the truth is bill and ted's excellent
adventure set up an impossible premise
for face
music to deliver on it works in the
first film to say that sometime in the
future berlin ted will write a song that
brings about universal peace and harmony
but that premise breaks down when you
have to show that song in the third film
music is subjective which means that
there's no song anyone could write that
all audiences would buy as a song that
would save the world
yet the entire plot of face and music
relies on bill and ted performing such a
song by the end of the film the solution
to this problem
turns out to be surprisingly simple and
elegant it's not about the song itself
but about humanity uniting across time
and space to create music together
one of the main themes of the bill and
ted trilogy has always been about
friends and strangers working together
to accomplish great things
so even if the song isn't entirely your
jam there's no need to suspend disbelief
because as thea and billy explain
at the end of the film it wasn't so much
the song that made the difference it was
everyone playing it together
bill and ted movies have always marched
to the beat of their own drum in the
logic department
but the reasoning of face and music
seemed a little nonsensical even by bill
and ted standards
first there's a question of how none of
the future bill and teds
seem to have any knowledge of the 2020
concert until the bill and ted from
2067.
yet that you'll remember going on the
same time travelling journey that we see
play out in the film
as evidenced by the 2025 villain ted
being able to hatch an elaborate plan to
try to deceive their past selves
there's also the issue of why rufus
seemed to know exactly how and when
berlin ted would save the world but then
no one else in the future did the great
leaders seem to have no knowledge of how
the concert came about who performed it
or what the song sounded like all she
had was rufus's information
even though she had technology that put
all of time and space right at her
fingertips
plus how do any of these futures even
exist if all of reality collapsed in on
itself in 2020
all of it adds up to a time travel plot
that mirrors the wackiness of the first
film
but lacks the internal cohesion if face
and music wanted to play around with a
bunch of alternate realities that could
have been cool
but it doesn't really work when the plot
is focused on maintaining a reality that
already exists
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]